Okay, everyone one of the most interesting characters to watch in Avengers: Infinity War was Star-lord Peter Quill a.k.a Guardians Chris
We're gonna be touching on plot point in the movie here so again spoiler warning go watch the movie great
You're back, okay?
And Avengers infinity war one really the thrilling fight sequence for me showed the Avengers come closer than ever to actually
Getting the best of Thanos on Titan. Iron Man, Spider-Man
Doctor Strange, Star-lord, Drax, Mantis, and Nebula combine their strengths to restrain Thanos
Trapping him in a near comatose state as Iron Man and Spider-Man tried to pull off the Infinity Gauntlet from his hand. Spider-Man comes
Agonisingly close we see that thing wriggle and slide by the way we see it's a size of entirety of Peter Parker
He's like pulling this garbage can sized thing off his hand
At this same moment Star-lord realizes what Thanos did to acquire the soul stone
sacrificed Gamora
Peter Quill loses it to and he attacks Thanos, breaking him out of that
Restraint, allowing him to fight back each of the Avengers and then Thanos throws a moan at them
And he overwhelms Stark, and it gets the time stone
Then he pieces out back to earth where he uses that time stone to reverse Scarlet Witch destroying vanished
Visions mind stone had he not gotten time stone. He never would have gotten the mind stone
He never would gotten all six. His master plan would have been foiled
So this brings up the question guys is this all Star Lords fault
Or do you believe if Star-Lord kept his cool and stomached his grief. They could have gotten the gauntlet and Thanos would have been finished
Star-lord and the other unlucky unlucky half of the universe would still be here
I don't know guys how much do you think Star-Lord is to blame is this impulsive anguish over Gamora worth this mistake, it's
100% his fault completely entirely uh
There's no doubt about the fact that this moment is his fault that they lose that
Moment mm-hmm that moment is his fault
But I'll say that in all of the possibilities of what could have happened that Doctor Strange
perceived if it's over 14 million
he had to
Absolutely gain the time stone in this moment we see it again
Shown when he trade Stark's life for it. I feel like this is actually Dr.
Strange allowing certain things to happen we need him to hold on to the gauntlet
And he needs to leave here with the time stone
It's one of its the only of the versions that it will possibly happen
This is the only one, but we will eventually win even though
We'll lose right now
So do you think the Doctor Strange?
Knew that and did not share the entire thing cuz he knew Star Lord was gonna react that way
I think so I think there's no way they could have told the team it's like you're gonna try real hard
But then Star-Lord is gonna mess it up for all of its sleep. It involves star-lord
Eventually being one of the people to fade away, right?
And I think that answer comes also in that moment where Tony's like, "what you let me
Live? like we're not even-" y'all kind of that way a little right didn't it feel like for a second
It's like doesn't it feel earned
It didn't feel like it, but he's now my best friend, so I you know we don't trade live or something
It didn't feel like that in that moment. It's because Doctor Strange is playing four dimensional test
But you know what I mean
Yes, totally on another level
And he's allowing events to take place including letting him mess things up in that moment for me. I
Didn't think that that specific part was planned. I think this was a genuine mistake that
That does actually you do bring up a good point if you saw 14 million outcomes
There's not one where star-lord freaked out, but he found out his girlfriend
Got killed by her dad, but in from the way
I interpret it watching it like then now you bring up a good point, but after I saw the movie. I thought that
Honestly this was just an outcome
he hadn't seen just yet and
Star-lord freaking out did ruin the one way they could have gotten out of this and in his and all the futures he saw
He saw that Tony Stark might be the only one that could like not
It could be one of the only people to figure out how to undo this so that's why he's like
We can't let him die because he's one of our only hopes yeah
super fascinating possibility
And it's it's really answered by a your belief of your own answer here to the question
Did he mean there's one time where we win this thing now or?
On the other side of half the people vanishing
We win at the end of infinity war 2  - I think he was looking at immediate
There's a it's kind of hard to look at like
Already when he said 14 million like way too many times
You look there way too many futures that they just picked a big number of the writers did
And I feel like it was more immediate, but you do bring up a good point so just depend
It's it's interesting how much do you want to consider dr.?
Strange to be omniscient and a God in this movie as the screenwriter and the director of the movie
You're kind of a god you decide who comes in when and how these events unfold?
And I was thinking about this like oh why have nebula come back and oh they needed nebula to be in the scene in this
Moment so that she could confirm that Gamora died because she was part of that conversation earlier
But if the screenwriter knew that like I have a feeling strange would know that as well
He knew that nebula needed to crash her ship him to
Titan in this moment and help them restraint Thanos for a moment
But he also knew that that would involve her sharing that information with
Star-lord and that that could cause chaos I think that vision yeah
I think it's very possible that stark that Doctor Strange saw in this one timeline in the future where things work
nebula and Tony Stark
I think the way the screenwriters paired things down to just have the essential members of the MCU there in that final battle
I think that's what strange saw as well
We're only gonna have the people were still alive who need to be there to actually take damage down in the end brain
But I'm not gonna leave what you said if he's omniscient if the eye of agamotto gives him the ability to see all eventualities
But if he's again like Nicholas Cage in the movie Next and he can only see just a few minutes ahead
And he saw 14 million
Well there is a twist of next. I can see further
We could argue that
From star-lords point of view a very selfish move especially since he had several scenes with Gamora where he was arguing on whether or not
He would kill her. He pulled the trigger
Unfortunately bubbles came out and very cartoonish hilarious way
He was totally ready to kill her and it seems like he should have already detached himself at least on a slight emotional level
So that when he's confronted with saving half the known universe he can at least hold that back
But more taking a swing at the guy, maybe I...  I kind of agree yes, it is his fault
I do agree because actually just when you think about it's like yeah 100%
It's his fault, but also I do like the perspective of like no..  the endgame when he mentions. This is the endgame now
It's that this is the this is the last. This is the you have to complete
What's gonna happen next I gave you everything that you can possibly know and have it your in your arsenal
And you can do this yeah, so I do like I do think your theory is more correct
We can also talk this up to like in war just things happen. Nothing should ever go to plan right?
It's a little bit more interesting to see it's way more interesting
I would say to see Peter quill screw up this place in the movie, and we're not talking about did he trip on a rock
He did something that his character chose to do or maybe didn't even chose just to do because of the thing most important to him
In the world was gone or in the universe really was gone
So he doesn't really have a great reason to save the universe as much he used to in that moment and the thing that did
It is right there in that moment so they definitely
Justified it so we don't necessarily
Need to even say the wrong thing and I'll give you a twist on the same question
It could go all the way the other way if Doctor Strange was right
This is the one time then is them winning at the end of infinity war to Peter Quill's fault. Oh
Yeah, you could yeah, you could have these thought experiments in infinite ways
It's just my plan that's kind of yeah, if it came back around that way
It was me!!
At least at least like Thanos didn't sit on his mixtape volume 2 and that's why he was pissed off
Well let us know what you think in the comments down below and reminder to subscribe to the new rock stars for all of our
Infinity War coverage, thanks guys